so what we got here that Mike tell me
tell me well we have a strange graph
drawn out on my page a comic on a
previous video asked about Dijkstra's
shortest path now I happen to have
implemented dives a shorter path for one
of the pieces of research I was doing a
few years ago so I thought I'm at least
somewhat place to have to give an
opinion on it so let's talk about Dyson
shortest path what it is where it's used
and so on path finding algorithms are
obviously quite important we use them
all the time on Google Maps or on our
sat-nav system all right there was a
recent video on satellite navigation and
how it works
but of course that's only half the story
finding out where you are exactly is the
first part of the problem the second
part is I want to go over here what's
the best route to do this okay
route planning also comes in on things
like routing so if you've got a network
and lots of rooters what's the best way
to route those packets through which
ports to get to your destination a
quickest so things like this now dives
to shortest paths sees a lot of use in
all of these things and extensions of it
so for example a star search so I've
drawn out an approximation of a road
system on this piece of paper so we're
going to use the analogy of roads for
this one because I think it's a good
good example of types of shortest paths
and we're trying to start here at s and
get down to e right this is broadly
speaking a small version of what a
sat-nav does when you say how do I get
there right now each of these nodes
represents a junction so the vertices on
the graph so a could be around about be
the T Junction doesn't really matter
actually bees more of a roundabout
because it has four output anyway each
of these numbers represents how hard it
is to get along that road so that in
real life would be whether it was a
motorway or a highway whether it was a
country road with a load of potholes
maybe there's a tree down it and so you
can't get through that road right so in
the Dijkstra implementation that I am
familiar with and most diverse
implementations smaller is better okay
so broadly speaking this route here is
kind of like our motorway right twos
ones that's good this one is a bit of a
faff you know for some maybe mid Li a
roads right and this seven here that
you're falling in a four
and you know you've got water in the
engine and it's bad the question is how
do we find a route from here to here now
of course this is a small graph so
actually what we could just do is just
search all the way through it by hand or
using a very simple sort of brute-force
search approach and kind of get the best
go right but if you think of the UK or
the US or some other countries massive
road network we can't afford to do that
right we have to be a bit smarter about
how we look through and we also want to
know absolutely that once we found a
route it is in fact the shortest route
and we didn't just miss one
what deixar does is basically similar to
a sort of brute force flood-fill search
through this space but does it in a kind
of in the order that makes the most
sense based on how fast these roads are
so it will check the quickest roads
first so to do Dijkstra we need a few
things first of all we know obviously
need a graph right and when we need some
some idea of how long the path is to
let's say B once we've calculated it or
something like it so at the very
beginning of our search we have s we are
at earth as for star right it's for
start yes which confused me because some
of the other letters are just in order
and then these two aren't been anyway s
has a distance of zero my it costs me
nothing to get to s because I'm already
there everything else I'll just put a
couple out just to show you a B and K
have a distance of infinity because that
basically says we haven't looked yet we
don't know how far so for all we know it
might not be possible to get there
No and finally E it's just the same
disability with a smiley face to say
that we've made it right now this
structure here that I'm going to create
is called a priority queue each of these
will have a distance but they've all did
also by that distance so the shortest
ones at the top that's important and
we'll do it as we go through so let's
start our search we start to s and we
look through the neighbors of s and we
say right well a it cost me seven to get
to a write it's a bit of a pain so we
were at zero distance cost of seven so
now we're at seven right
so a I scrapped my Infinity and I write
seven all right so a is seven okay
a is still the second shortest path
currently because really I was infinity
yeah B is zero plus two so bad
so let's just put a 2 in there this is
all even though we haven't actually got
to the end yet you just looking at the
numbers we can't get to e without having
a look through all of these junctions so
this is what we're doing and we're
working away in a smart way now B is in
this priority queue but it has a lower
number than a so it takes its place at
the top of a line okay so that's good so
far
finally the only other thing connected
to s is C which is got a weighting of 3
so let's just find C in my list of
course shuffled thingies and there we go
and hopefully how Dijkstra work will
start to become clear once you see what
I do next so C is 3 the only other thing
that of course I forgot is while we're
doing our search we have to keep a track
of where we've been so B for example we
know has a distance of 2 through the
path s ok so s was the previous version
right that's also true of a and also
true of see now at we swap see an a so
now we have them in order all we have is
our still infinity now s is done right
so we can take it away and put it in our
finished pile over here right s we don't
worry about any more the next step step
is to see where is the current shortest
path where it's B my beads got the
lowest number so let's start looking at
B so if we look at B we've already been
to s so we ignore it we can go to D so
let's put in a D and D is the distance
to B plus whatever this road is which is
6 2 plus 4 is 6 and the route through D
which is shortest is currently going
through B and we'll put that in now 6
goes in just above a ok there we go now
we can also go to be from a we haven't
finished with a yet it's just sitting in
this queue and currently the distance to
a is 7 right but actually the distance
to be was 2 and the distance to a from B
is 3 which is 5 so actually taking this
detour here which looks longer is
actually shorter because of this tree
ormaline or something like that right so
remember you know this isn't
representative of the actual physical
distance from s to C so we've updated D
and a is now shorter right so we kept we
take our aid and we say well now the
route is 5 not 7 it's decreased and it's
no longer a shortest path from s to a
it's from B so look scribble out s right
like I'm getting too much technical
needs but
worry about it so hey now overtakes D in
our priority queue all right so that's
looking good okay h b had a length of 2
H has a length of 1 so H has a distance
of 3 B is done right we've done B we can
count that as done so C next right so
we're here
we can't go to s we can only go to L
that's a nice easy one so I need to find
out so L goes to C and it's 3 plus 2 is
5 so L comes in just underneath value
like this so C's done so we look at H
and we say what's next from H we can
look at F so f will get 3 plus another 3
so about 6 via H and then G is H which
is 3 plus 2 so that's 5 hey next we've
already been to s we've already been to
B so we start to get a little bit faster
now we've seen some stuff already what
we're basically saying is we know what
the shortest path to B is because we've
already seen it so we can only look at
new things so we look at D D is
currently 6 via B a is currently 5 5
plus 4 is 9 which is bigger than the
audience so we make no change the
shortest path to D does not go through a
so we don't worry about that ok he's
done
next up L L can't go to see we've
already been there I and J both have a
length of 4 so that's just fine those
two I and J need on all of them right so
these both go through L and they both
have a path length of 9 9 okay so these
go and they're both long but they go if
in front of all the Infinity ones but
but down at the bottom here
all right the audio isn't important so
how we doing L is done so then you can
see what's about to happen right we
start with G G's got a distance of 5
we've already been to H let's go to e
and so we say e goes back to G and has a
length of 5 6 7 and we're there right
and then the final step is just a
backtrack our route based on where we've
been so e goes to G we can skip these
aren't used G goes to H H goes to b and
b go straight to s and that is our
shortest route through this graph it's
bound by Dijkstra the idea is but if
this guar for much much bigger you would
prioritize looking
motorways first because they have less
weight and you would prioritize
physically short distances anything that
you can to try and make your search a
bit quicker when you're searching to
let's say travel from Nottingham to
London you don't look at the roads in
Scotland at least not first because it's
unlikely they're going to be the
shortest ones what you do is you get
yourself to the m1 and start travelling
down towards London as quickly as
possible that leads us to one last
problem with Dijkstra which is perhaps
for another video but I'll just I'll
just introduce it if you imagine a
situation where I'm my house and let's
say my house is here and s and this is
sort of m1 Junction right which happens
to be about junking 26 but we'll call
this a alright and then this is where
I'm going in this direction so lots of
nodes along here and there's lots of
nodes along here and this is my
destination down here on the end of its
motorway because of a slight traffic jam
these all have slightly higher weights
than these because divert doesn't build
any idea of the direction you're
traveling any kind of heuristic about
what you're doing in a sort of smarter
way it's going to look up here first
it's going to travel all the way up this
motorway as far as it can and only
change direction when it becomes the
shortest path to do so so what you need
to do if you're going to actually
implement a sat-nav is be a little bit
smarter
don't start sort of looking to all the
fast roads look at the fast roads that
are going roughly in the right direction
because otherwise you might be wasting a
lot of time and then lead
red right I think I've got them all he I
think he's got a little checkered flag
on that's no well II yeah well how do I
do a checkered flag smiley face that
means we're done right okay